cette condamnation à la prison à
perpétuité d'un voyou du football
britannique
cela s'est passé à l'ombre je disais dès
hier soir le jeune homme était accusé
encontre d'avoir grièvement blessé
le tenancier d'un pub au soir d'un match
qui opposait le club de chelsea à
manchester united les anglais sont
divisés sur cette condamnation qui est
très sévère et de toute façon qui est
exemplaire
or il y avait un match cet après midi
chelsea notre correspondant à londres à
l'unc ans s est donc allé voir ce qui se
passait dans les tribunes voici son
reportage bien passé cet après midi ni
sur le stade de chelsea ni aux alentours
bien que l'ambiance d'un match de
football
le mauvais temps la présence massive de
la police allait sans doute découragé
les hooligans
ces voyous du sport sur mon responsable
de bagad des ordres à l'occasion des
matchs des hooligans qui ont peut être
commencé à réfléchir à la terrible
sentence qui est hier soir frappé l'un
des leurs kelly nuitonne 25 ans
hooligans de chelsea a été condamné à la
prison à vie un de ses amis à 8 en
décembre dernier qu'elle von gunten et
son gang avait sauvagement attaqué le
barman de ce peuple lui tailladant
longuement visage à l'aide de verre
brisé
100 points de suture et les et cathy sa
vie à les membres du gang avait aussi
arraché à coups de temps une partie de
l'oreille d'un passant le juge a
justifié sa terrible sentence se sont
hâtés vie des hommes comme calvin
whitten qui font passer aux yeux du
monde
toute une génération de britanniques
pour des bouts de violentes dangereuse
et antisportive mon fils est un bouc
émissaire a déclaré la mère de calvin
whittle en quittant le tribunal
il apprécie tannique l'opinion publique
les hommes politiques
il a été du juge sans doute kelvin
whitten at il payé pour tous les autres
et pour la honte qui prouve la grande
majorité des britanniques devant ces
images ou au souvenir de la tragédie du
heysel et répondent les commentateurs il
vaut mieux point des ports si on veut
essayer de remettre de l'ordre
pourtant ce soir aux alentours du stade
les amateurs de football étaient encore
sans illusion
s'il faut des donations ali pour les
arrêter qu'on leur donne je ne suis pas
si cela suffira à les arrêter
ça ne va pas arranger les choses au
contraire surtout par ici au fait cet
après midi celle ci a gagné par 4 à 2
contre 2 une gamme forêt zac